Thor, the Norse god of thunder, has gone through
many changes during his time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, including his personality.
Alongside his learned wisdom and merit, Thor
has become quite the jokester. Here are the god of
thunder's jokes in the MCU, ranked worst to best.
The first entry into our rundown of the god of
thunder's jokes in the MCU comes in his very first
appearance, 2011's eponymous solo outing. Having
just been put in place by his father Odin, played
by Anthony Hopkins, Thor's trying to convince
his compatriots to go with him to Jotunheim.
He hopes they’ll see how the Frost Giants
managed to break through Asgard's defenses
in their attempt to steal the
casket. As Lady Sif reminds him,
Odin forbade such an action, but Thor
persists in his manipulation. Thor asks,
"My friends, have you forgotten
all that we have done together?"
For Fandral and Hogun, Thor points out that he'd
led them into the most glorious of battles. To
sway Volstagg, he reminds him that the
delicacies he thought were so succulent
that he felt he'd died and gone to Valhalla.
And then, to Sif, he posed a simple question.
"And who proved wrong all who
scoffed at the idea that a young
maiden could be one of the fiercest
warriors this realm has ever known?”
“I did.”
“True, but I supported you."
It's a coin flip as to whether you
think he was trying to steal Sif's
thunder — pun obviously intended — but
he did give her due credit in the end.
In Thor's second standalone movie, "The Dark
World," he's cracking more jokes than in the
first, probably as a result of hanging out with
Tony Stark in 2012's first "Avengers" film.
When Lady Sif is leading Asgard's armies and
the Warriors Three in battle on Hogun's home
world of Vanaheim and clearly thinks things are
going swimmingly, Thor shows up on the scene.
He quickly takes out some enemy combatants
with his trusty hammer, Mjolnir, and Sif is
perturbed at his arrival. She complains,
and Thor responds with a well-timed joke.
"I've got this completely under control.”
“Is that why everything's on fire?"
Total burn, Thor!
As the battle on Vanaheim rages on in "Thor 2,"
with the enemy surrounding Asgard's warriors,
an angry roar stops the fight in mid action.
Everyone looks around for the source of such
a ferocious rumble. That's when a giant Kronan
warrior appears and marches toward Thor. MCU
fans who've seen "Thor: Ragnarok may think
this massive humanoid warrior made of stone is
the same type of being as Korg, played by Taika
Waititi. They'd be right in thinking this is a
Kronan and thus the same species as Korg. However,
according to the DVD commentary for "Thor:
The Dark World" this Kronan actually is Korg,
and the version who appears in "Ragnarok" has been
retconned by Waititi, who also directed the film.
Now, Thor's a big dude, but this version of Korg
is massive and the Norse god of thunder is about
waist height on the brute. But
Thor, of course, isn't fazed.
"I accept your surrender."
And when Thor backs up his joke by smashing
Korg to pieces, he gets in another zinger.
"Anyone else?"
When Rhodey, played by Don Cheadle, took the Iron
Man Mark II armor during "Iron Man 2" and became
War Machine, he stepped into the big leagues.
Viewers catch a conversation in Avengers: Age of
Ultron where Rhodey is regaling Tony Stark, Maria
Hill, and Thor with a story of his own adventures.
"So I take the tank, fly it
right up to the general's palace,
drop it at his feet. I'm like,
'Boom, you looking for this?'"
A confused Thor asks if that's the whole story.
Rhodey says that it is, that it’s a War Machine
story. Thor laughs and responds, saying,
"Oh, it's very good then. It's impressive."
Quality save, Thor. Fortunately for Rhodey,
the story does indeed kill later on when
he tells it to some non-Avenger partygoers.
As Thor attempts to smuggle Loki out of Asgard in
"The Dark World," Loki is doing one of the things
he does best: annoying Thor. Loki first
takes the form of an Asgardian warrior,
then takes up his own likeness again and
makes his brother look like Sif. Then,
Loki takes the form of one of Thor's more recent
allies, Captain America, played by Chris Evans,
and offers to have a rousing discussion
about truth, honor, and patriotism.
Loki realizes that nagging Thor isn't working out,
so he finally just asks Thor for a
weapon to make the escape easier.
Thor locks eyes with Loki and appears to be
rustling around for something for Loki to wield.
"At last, a little common sense."
As it turns out, Thor did use his common
sense: he handcuffed the trickster.
"I thought you liked tricks."
It's no secret Loki has done a great many
horrible things. He's betrayed pretty much
everyone he knows, Thor included. He's
manipulated everyone he's ever met,
Thor included. He's tried to kill pretty much
everyone with whom he's come into contact, Thor
included. These shenanigans play out over the
course of the first two Thor solo films and the
first Avengers movie. When we get to "Ragnarok,"
it's more of the same, whether on Asgard,
Earth, or Sakaar. As Thor, Valkyrie, and Bruce
Banner, discuss their exit strategy and how to
get through a wormhole terrifyingly dubbed
the Devil's Anus, our favorite trickster
chimes in with an offer of assistance, causing
Banner to pull the other two into a sidebar.
Banner says that he had just been talking to Loki,
and he was perfectly ready to kill any of them.
Valkyrie agrees, mentioning Loki had tried to kill
her. Thor, who is the obvious expert on Loki's
attempts at murder, concurs, noting his adopted
brother has tried to take his life on, quote,
"many, many occasions" before
describing one in particular.
"He transformed himself into a snake,
and he knows that I love snakes. So I
went to pick up the snake to admire it,
and he transformed back into himself, and he
was like 'Ya! It's me!' and he stabbed me."
It’s no secret that Loki has a thing for
stabbing people — especially in the back,
but at least Thor got a funny story out of it.
Dr. Bruce Banner deals with a lot of doubts
and insecurities — given the great beast
that lives within him. While he's able to summon
the Hulk at will, getting the big guy to stand
down is an entirely different matter. But, by the
time "Age of Ultron" rolls around, he seems to
have developed a system of deescalation with Black
Widow, involving holding hands and a lullaby. That
doesn't stop him from being dejected about
the entire situation after they had to call
a Code Green in their attack on Strucker's
compound in the opening sequence of the film.
As they're flying back to
Avengers HQ aboard the Quinjet,
Natasha asks Bruce when he's going to trust
her and he responds with the obvious answer
that it's not her that he doesn't trust. So she
enlists another teammate — perhaps the wrong
one — to weigh in, asking Thor what he thinks of
the Hulk. Thor responds with good humor, as usual.
"The gates of Hell are filled
with the screams of his victims."
When he sees that neither Natasha or
Banner is in the mood for his jokes,
he quickly walks back his remarks.
"No, no, wounded screams. Mainly whimpering,
a great deal of complaining and
tales of sprained deltoids and gout."
Another quality save.
In "Ragnarok," Thor proves his mettle by surviving
an encounter with the Grandmaster's champion,
aka The Hulk. Afterwards, Thor's living
conditions improve immensely. He's no
longer living among the rabble of lower
card fighters like Korg. As a main eventer,
he's in penthouse-level quarters with
his opponent, the Hulk. There's training
equipment befitting a champion, including
what every noble warrior needs: a hot tub.
Great for soaking sore muscles, it's an
essential tool for a fighter's rest and recovery.
We're guessing most athletes choose to soak in
a pair of trunks or other undergarment when in
a group setting, but not our Hulk, which Thor
finds out when pressing him for information.
Thor asks him how he arrived on Sakaar. Hulk
explains that he came there when the Quinjet
he took at the end of "Age of Ultron" crash landed
there. Well, he offered the one-word response of
"Quinjet" and then mimed a crash with his hand,
but it's all there in the subtext. Naturally Thor
wants to know where the Quinjet is now so he
could potentially use it himself. Having just
demonstrated his propensity for showing rather
than telling, Hulk gets out of the tub fully nude,
to point out where the crashed Quinjet is,
giving Thor an eyeful as he walks to the window.
"That's, ah, naked. Very naked.
Hmmm. That's in my brain now."
Thor's only got a few friends at his disposal when
stranded on Sakaar in "Ragnarok" and they're not
exactly keen on helping him escape. Valkyrie can't
seem to stop drinking or using that obedience disk
on him, so she's not going to be of much help.
Korg and Miek are willing but they're locked
up with all the other slaves — sorry, prisoners
with jobs — so he can't expect much out of them.
He needs Hulk's help and he’s going to do his best
to convince the great green brute to help him out,
even if it means a bit of
manipulation. Thor tells Hulk,
"This is what friends do,
they support each other."
Even so, Hulk insists that Thor
is Banner's friend and not his.
"Banner's friend.”
“I don't even like Banner! He’s all, 'I'm
into numbers and science and stuff.'"
Once Hulk reverts to Bruce Banner, having
seen Natasha's message aboard the Quinjet
he just wrecked, Thor tries a bit of
the same with Hulk's human counterpart.
Though, it may be with perhaps a bit less finesse.
"I just told you if I turn into the Hulk , I'm
never gonna come back again and you don't care!"
Thor has upset Banner and has made him feel used,
especially when Thor says that Hulk is the
fire that he needs to defeat his sister.
Banner tells Thor that he’s not his friend. Thor,
then, reverses what he said to Hulk earlier:
"No, I don’t even like the Hulk. He's like
'Roar, smash, smash, smash.' I prefer you."
As "Endgame" is coming to a close, it ties up
its myriad loose ends in an extended finale.
We see Thor entrust the future of
the New Asgard colony on Earth to
Valkyrie before boarding the ship
with the Guardians of the Galaxy.
"The Asgardians of the Galaxy, back
together again. Where to first?"
On board, Thor immediately makes himself at
home, and changes the map that Star-Lord,
aka Peter Quill is looking at. Star-Lord, annoyed,
changes it back and decides it's time to lay down
the law with the newbie. After a brief back
and forth about who's in charge on the ship,
Drax suggests they fight for the leadership role.
"I got some blasters unless
you guys want to use knives.”
“Oh, yes, please, use knives."
Quill and Thor both laugh, and Thor
cheerfully explains that they don't
have to fight, because it's clear who's in charge.
"There shall be no knifing one another;
everybody knows who's in charge."
After a brief, uncertain pause, Quill asks,
quote, "Me, right?" Thor's response says it all.
"Yes, you. Of course, of course, of course."
About 50 minutes into "The Avengers," the team
sits down for its first unofficial team meeting
on the bridge of the massive SHIELD helicarrier.
Before Tony Stark shows up, Thor discusses with
the other heroes the film's primary antagonist,
Loki. Nick Fury has just gotten done interrogating
the god of mischief and Cap asks Thor what
he thinks his brother's plan might be and
wonders why Loki let them take him into custody.
After all, Cap points out, Loki can't exactly
lead his army while aboard the helicarrier.
Banner posits that they shouldn't focus on Loki.
"That guy's brain is a bag full of
cats. You could smell crazy on him."
The god of thunder takes a surprising amount
of offense to this. He warns Banner to watch
his words, saying that while Loki might be
a villain, he is still a prince of Asgard.
"And he is my brother.”
“He killed 80 people in two days.”
“He's adopted."
Things get tense in the elevator scene
in "Ragnarok," as Loki leads Thor to the
Grandmaster's ship. Loki says he's probably
better off staying on Sakaar and Thor agrees,
to his surprise. Thor says Sakaar is
perfect for his brother, that it's, quote,
“savage, chaotic, lawless.” Thor thinks Loki will
do great there. Loki's taken aback, asking Thor if
he truly thinks so little of him and Thor replies
that he actually once thought the world of Loki.
But, while there might still be some
good in the cantankerous god of mischief,
he concedes that've been walking separate
paths for a long time. After a pregnant pause,
Loki somberly says it's probably for the best that
they never see each other again, and Thor twists
the knife, patting him on the back and reminding
him by saying that it’s what he’s always wanted.
Suddenly, Thor has an idea and brightens the mood,
suggesting they do the tried and true "Get Help"
routine. Loki declines. Thor reminds him that
it works every time and Loki says that it's
humiliating. Thor asks if Loki has a better plan,
which he doesn’t. So, Thor concludes that they
should do it, while Loki is still insistent that
they will not. Spoiler alert: they do "Get Help."
"Get help! Please! My brother,
he’s dying! Get help! Help him!"
Afterward, Thor has clearly enjoyed the routine,
while Loki complains that he still hates it.
"It's humiliating.”
“Not for me it's not."
When it comes to comparing adopted siblings
Thor and Loki, their respective strengths
are pretty clear. Thor is the clear winner
when it comes to physical might and combat,
while Loki is obviously the more cerebral of
the two demigods. It should be no surprise,
considering one is the warrior god of thunder and
the other is the trickster god of mischief. As
such, it's rare that Thor gets one over one the
sneaky Loki. Even so, Loki does underestimates
Thor, having gotten the better of him for so long.
But Thor is capable of growth, as he demonstrates
while they're heading to the Grandmaster's ship in
"Ragnarok," and he posits that Loki has stagnated.
After they perform the hilarious "Get Help" sneak
attack routine, Loki slinks off to a control
panel to turn Thor in while a magic double walks
alongside his brother. Of course, Thor knew that
would happen too. During his big speech in the
elevator, before suggesting they do "Get Help,"
Thor planted one of the Grandmaster's obedience
disks on Loki when patting him on the back. After
triggering the device in the hangar, he explains
that Loki's becoming predictable. Then, he makes
sure to put the remote for the obedience disk
somewhere Loki can reach it. Okay, not really.
"I'll just put this over here for you."
The open scene of “Ragnarok”
begins with Thor narrating,
supposedly to us, but maybe
to the skeleton in his cage.
“I know what you’re thinking, 'Oh no!
Thor's in a cage, how did this happen?'"
He explains that, sometimes, you have to get
captured in order to get a candid response
from someone. Before the bottom drops out
of the cage and the god of thunder is left
dangling by a length of chain, Thor
wonders aloud how long they'll be there.
But where exactly is he? Thor's location, as
it turns out, is the fiery realm of Muspelheim,
inhabited by fire demons, the
chief of whom is Thor's captor,
Surtur. But even chained up in front of a fire
demon, Thor manages to sneak in a good joke.
"Thor, son of Odin.”
“Surtur, son of ... a b----!"
Clearly, Thor's been spending
too much time around Tony Stark.
Thor's best joke in the MCU is a quip that's
a bit understated but absolutely hilarious.
After preventing the end of the world in
"Ragnarok," Thor returns to Asgard from
Muspelheim, having ripped Surtur's tiara off.
After witnessing someone he's pretty sure is
not Odin taking in a live performance of "The
Tragedy of Loki of Asgard," Thor unmasks Loki
with the threat of splattering his brother with
Mjolnir. Then he demands to see his father,
whom he believes Loki has spirited away. To
accomplish that, a pre-Executioner Skurge
uses the bifrost to send them to Earth, where Loki
and Thor witness the demolition of the Shady Acres
Care Home in New York City. Loki swears he left
Odin right there, to which Thor asks if he means
on the sidewalk where they're standing or where
the building is being demolished. Unsurprisingly,
Loki doesn't think he's to blame. After another
sarcastic remark from Thor, Loki responds,
“How was I supposed to know? I can't
see into the future; I'm not a witch.”
“No? Then why do you dress like one?"
Funny and true. With the black-on-black
suit and shoulder-length greasy hair,
Loki indeed looks like he just
stepped off the Hogwarts Express.
Take your best guess which House he'd belong
to. We're pretty sure it wouldn't be Hufflepuff.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.